all right let's try e4
king pawn opening
all right sicilian
c3 sicilian
let's give it a shot here
uh-huh
okay
i've looked at this variation from the
black side recently
okay
i'll go with the e5 let's see how black
addresses this structure
let us see
hmm
i'll be able to offer some insight with
this one
um
what move is white here
okay
i'm gonna go with the bishop to f4
i think black really needs to know what
he's doing here to
successfully address
the pressure against e5
let's see what black's next move is
all right let's
let's pin that knight now on queen a5 i
have knight c3 to defend my bishop
and what i'm looking to do right now is
what
actually i don't know that this was best
well we're gonna go with it
what's black gonna do now
e6
f6
knight h6 a6 not saying any of these are
great
okay
so bishop to d7 a more
reserved approach this pawn is now
unprotected
uh
let's go with knight c3 let's strike
at the weakness that has been created as
a result of bishop to d6
so will there be e6
if e6
i won't be so welcome to a light square
bishop exchange
on e6
on e6 this would be a weakness okay my
knight is pinned
connect my knights
um
connect my knights or not
hmm
i'm not sure which what is best knight
f3 or knight to
e2
um
hang on for a second is something tricky
being threatened here
no even if it is if my opponent is a
couple moves behind
with getting their king safe
i might have to go into some gambit mode
if knight takes pawn because this guy
will be hit twice
maybe i could have considered queen to
d2 that seems a little bit awkward but
well that's still not even meeting some
possibility of knight takes on e5 okay
we're not having that
um
bishop takes knight pawn takes here i'm
helping black to develop
i'm just going to castle
and uh work against this pawn here look
for some counter play against this guy
if pawn takes my queen is brought to
life and then there'll be two pieces
hitting here
okay
so
bishop takes knight or go elsewhere
bishop takes knight and then
yeah bishop takes knight definitely i
don't i want the move back
i don't i don't want my opponent
oh okay this is a serious weakness right
here what i was gonna maybe consider is
e6 but
i'm seeing something maybe even better
queen d2 i think is very uncomfortable
for black
because where does he develop
knight h6 is ruled out
i've seen from this opening the move g5
not in this particular position just
this opening
the move g5 but
not in this line here
okay
extreme measures here
black is taking king f7 how do i get at
that king
this seems very useful
i could also look to play on c5
i think i like that better if my knight
gets on c5 he's going to be an
animal i'm going to shoot for that
a3 b4 knight a4 to c5 would come with
tempo
two of those four moves
are coming with tempo
b4 and a knight on c5
will black take or not
if pawn takes i'm going to take with my
pawn immediately not my bishop i'd much
rather keep more minor pieces on the
board because i have
a space advantage
so that's that's the general principle
basically be following
to help me with that move
that next move or that next decision so
this is very weakening this pawn is
going to fall
this is a big trouble queen takes on d5
i get the rook
like if the idea is to meet this with f
takes e
i have queen takes d5
this position should be crumbling for
the black side queen takes pawn is the
way to get the material back and defend
here
but she is planted now on a
on an open file i could take here but
i like the idea of grabbing another
tempo against the queen
anything better probably not this is the
first move that's really coming to mind
again i want to just keep this tension
if he can't move the rook can't move so
he's black is playing without these two
pieces
knight takes pawn or knight here is a
threat
okay
um
was thinking about
what
okay
knight here i think is
wrong
let's go with knight here first
i was thinking night here and then on
pawn takes i was going to go
night here but the queen could take my
knight at that point
i was looking i'm looking at this square
anticipating some capture here and then
my knight could play here
okay
and
now what
hmm
let's go here let's her ask the queen
just a little bit more
maybe i do want to take on this square
just to make sure i'm not losing any
material
there's no yeah you know what def i
could definitely take here because
if the knight is recapturing i get to
play it here if the pawn is recapturing
black is not developing
so maybe i should have considered still
keeping my bishop on f4 and made a
forward move pawn takes pawn i should
have been a bit more aggressive with
that last move
okay but the queen in the meantime has
to find a new home
53 each
all right let's run with that
i could i feel like okay this is dead
now
the pawn needed to capture
so he's going to be captured with a fork
this is just over now
i'm getting the bishop
pawn was pawn takes was needed
but
i'm sure this is what black wanted all
the while to just get their night
developed but in this case it's
tactically flawed all right good game
let's go back actually into a bigger
board this time
okay
oh and let me look at it from your
perspective i think i was looking at it
from my perspective last time
okay
bishop here bishop to f4
you know i didn't want to play knight f3
because i didn't want to allow this
bishop
pin
so i want to do something else knight
knight c3 bishop to f4
i went with bishop f4 because there's
some lines where we could have on the
white side the knights connected
like on knight f3 bishop g4 i could
connect my knights i'm making a move
here to reinforce my lead pawn my head
pawn
knight c6 bishop pin i don't think was
best i think i should be going for
knight f3 and on bishop pin knight d2
but bishop to b5 it was and now you
didn't want to have that structural
change
you know i thought when you played this
the intention is to meet bishop takes
knight with the bishop recapturing so in
the game when you recapture with the
pawn
my eyes immediately lit up about this c5
square became a hole and your pawn
became backward on
well what's now an open file
turns into a half open file he's he's an
issue
so i think if you are going to go with
this
you really should be capturing with your
bishop on bishop takes night
um is there something better here yeah
this is the thing i was talking about
this there's this
idea of playing knight to h6 in this
position
knight h6 to f5 or
just i'm throwing a couple things out
here knight h6 to f5
and i've also seen some lines with the
knight h6 f6
and then there's a little hole there
a little spot then for your knight to
jump into f7 if you want to go in the
direction of
applying pressure to this head pawn if
you really want to
influence
or if you want to put pressure on my e5
pawn you could do so with knight h6 f6
knight f7
but again you're not locked into that
there's ideas of knight h6
into f5 though
if you are going to plant your knight on
f5 you'll want to make sure your bishop
i think is out here on g4 if there's an
opportunity to pin the knight
suppose on knight h6 in this position
instead of bishop d7 suppose knight h6
on knight f3 you can first play bishop
g4
and then knight to f5 and then i'll have
some problems
of my own with defending my
uh the tail of my pawn structure
you'll have both knights converging on
it i'll have one less defender on the d4
square since your light square bishop is
exchanging itself off or pinning the
knight which is a defender of d4
and even this ensuing move a queen to b6
attacks the bishop but also pressurizes
d4 so these are just a couple other
things to
be aware of this deployment of knight to
h6
queen a5 pins the night i think here is
a moment where you could take this pawn
no i'm mistaken with that
or am i
yeah i am mistaken knight takes e5 is
not working
i was thinking it was working it's not
knight takes e5 bishop takes
bishop takes if bishop takes bishop i
take here with check first and only then
recapture and one other line is knight
takes e5 bishop takes and on bishop
takes b5
there's bishop takes bishop and you're
losing this rook
so this tactic isn't working
i thought it was during the game but
looking at it more closely it's not
after f6 you played a6 i think the
correct follow-up is to maybe follow
through here
follow up with the follow through
f takes e and then maybe e6 knight to e7
now that i'm castled your two moves
behind with castling i think this you
have to be really speedy with your
kingside deployment
kingside development
e takes d takes e6
get your knights connected get castled
and uh
you're gonna have a much better game for
sure
he's uh still a problem bishop but
you're in a position to recapture with
this
on bishop takes knight there's bishop
takes bishop
so you played a6 instead
and i think you certainly have to be
recapturing with the bishop there
queen d2 and now it's very difficult for
you to complete development
i had many choices here
but i wanted to focus on c5
the position is opening up with c5 you
get rid of this weakness but
at the same time you make d5 more
accessible so it's difficult spot
clearly at this point
i could have maybe done better with
certain decisions but
just from a general standpoint with a
timing standpoint
king's uncastled and these guys just
aren't playing and the position is wide
open really
okay
a good game let's
close out of this
you